وعلى جبهه المعارك في اوكرانيا لا تزال
مدينه بخموت في الشرقيه محور المعارك
الرئيسيه وفي احدث تطورات هناك قال افقيني
مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه قال
ان قواته اصبحت على مقربه من مركز المدينه
ونشرت وسائل الاعلام تابعه
على فيديو لافراد من الميليشيا وهم يرفعون
علما فوق مبنى في باخموت
ايضا قدر نائب حاكم الموالي لروسيا
ايغورسكي قدر خسائر الجيش الاوكراني خلال
معارك المدينه مدينه باخموت بنحو 70% من
قواته وقدر كيما كوفسكي عدد القوات
الاوكرانيه التي ما زالت داخل باخموت
ببضعه الاف واشار الى قيام القوات
الاوكرانيه بسحب بعض وحداتها من المدينه
من جانبه قال موقع ريبارا العسكريه الروسي
ان ميليشيا فاجنر وسعت محور هجومها في
شمال المدينه باتجاه بلده خرموفكا في مسعا
للسيطره على اخر طريق امن لنقل الدعم الى
الجيش الاوكراني في بخموت